in your face it's not my guys at least
you finally came over by the way the
house is amazing and it's so you thank
you is so me Oh mind if I get another of
course let me show you the way you guys
need anything oh they don't need
anything actually if they speak I'll
murder them well they've got everything
who's they thank you I said we've got
everything like we are at a party we are
we want did you just move in you want
some help
no I'm good job I'm gonna I'm gonna hit
the John maybe I'm okay that way that
way
[Music]
this isn't the bathroom Josh I can
explain I don't believe I haven't even
said anything yet Josh come on what do
you think you think I tied up Blake and
Ryan and like what just threw them in
their own closet I didn't until you just
said that what did you do to them are
they okay
Josh big movie stars alone each other
their houses all the time well what was
that that was Alexa Alexa please shut
the up nope nope nope nope I'm out
of here no no no come on something come
on can you just be quiet please I'm
thinking and Blake the next time that I
bake cookies for the crew don't make
better cookies for them the next day
we even be in this situation
[Music]
you